in September the year 1788 the Austrians
were yet again finding the Ottomans in
the so-called Habsburg Ottoman war most
of the Austrian army was large around
hundred thousand strong but was made up
of numerous ethnicities from all corners
of the Empire some who didn't even speak
German this crude army led by the Holy
Roman Emperor himself King Joseph ii was
scouting for the forces of the ottoman
military near the town of Carabas in
modern-day Romania as the day was coming
to an end the army decided to set up a
camp near the town next to the timís
River the Army's Vanguard a contingent
of who Tsar's continued to scout for the
Ottomans and cross the river however
found nothing more than some group of
Roma people or valakians offering to
sell barrels of schnapps liquor to the
soldiers naturally the soldiers took the
deal and got to drinking right away
seemingly forgetting their purpose there
in the first place
shortly after Somme de Infantry crossed
a river as well only to find a drunk
contingent of who Tsar's partying the
infantry wanted to join in and demanded
some of the barrels of alcohol for
themselves but the hussars refused as
they were the ones who bought it and
also were of higher status than a meager
infantryman soon a scuffle broke out and
the drunk who Tsar's made up makeshift
defences around the barrels suddenly in
the confusion a shot was fired by
someone and the drunken scuffle turned
into an all-out fight during the battle
some of the infantry started to yelled
courtesy toward sea meaning the Turks or
Ottomans the drunken confused who Tsar's
fled in fear of an ottoman attack with
the infantry being quick to follow all
while still attacking each other the
situation was made even worse when
Austrian officers made aware of the
problem tried to restore order by
yelling halt halt meaning stop however
many of the soldiers didn't speak German
and misheard the words as allah-allah
the Ottoman battle cry the hasar is now
convinced of an ottoman ambush ran
through the camp where an officer
mistook them for charging Ottoman
soldiers and ordered and artillery fire
with the entire camp now persuaded of an
ottoman attack the disorganized army
tried to flee the scene from an
imaginary enemy soldiers fired on every
shadow
thinking it could be the Ottomans and
the Emperor Joseph himself was knocked
down of his horse into a creek the
entire army now fighting a retreating
battle against itself suffered
reportedly anywhere up to ten thousand
casualties our credible sources for the
number more around 1,000 also in
addition to lost equipment a chest
containing the entire Army's payroll was
quote-unquote lost and several soldiers
were recorded as missing it was only
when the entire army finished its
retreat that the Austrians found out
what actually happened in count sabes
but now disorganized and in no position
to fight they had to leave the town
unprotected from the Ottoman forces now
there are many second-hand sources and
people who know better than to start a
pointless argument in the comments
section that will argue that such a
battle of krantz Abbas never happened
and that's not entirely true
so let's look at the facts we know for
sure we know that at one point during
the war the austrian army was in
conscious order surrounding area we also
know that this positioning makes
strategical sense as cannabis is an
important valley protecting the road
towards the hungarian plain on top of
that we know that the ottomans were
aware of some kind of a confusion within
the austrian army during september and
used this to their advantage forcing a
blockade of the upper Daniel so looking
at these facts and makes no sense for
the Austrian military to have withdrawn
from such a strategically important
place giving the Ottomans an upper hand
if something major like the disastrous
Battle of cannon savez didn't happen
thus we know something have had to have
happen for the Austrians to withdrew
from Kant's Abbas and we do know
something happened because few days
after at the start of October there was
an article about it in the real Isaiah
there were also other articles later
written about the battle but there were
very few and far apart but what they all
had in common was they all told a story
of some kind of a military blunder in
Karnes Abbas during that September now
that the actual battle happened exactly
as I presented it at the start of this
video no it did not the story changed
over time due to exaggerations by
soldiers fabrication by
countries to Austria multiple retellings
and sometimes just bad research power as
I mentioned before a true military
blunder did happen in cannabis but how
it exactly happened and to what extent
it happened we may most likely never
know